Miss France 2024 et sont les invités
exceptionnels de TPMP ce soir on va
revenir sur le sacre d' Gill regardez
c'était le moment du sacre c'était
samedi soir aux alentours de 4h du
matin Miss France 2024 et et
restera
Miss
norp et la
prière
[Applaudissements]
merci merci Cindy FA et merci FG Miss
France 2024 d'être avec nous
oui tu es au courant ve toi est-ce que
tu es tu es au courant ou qui fait du
bruit avec son micro je vais lesquinter
Cindy tu es au courant ouais est-ce que
j'ai dit EV oui d 21h30 tu l'as dit
voilà merci d'être là tu vois voilà
merci je l'ai dit direct vous en foutez
merci ça va merci d'être là en tout cas
non merci pour l'invitation et
franchement vous n'arrêtez pas en ce
moment j'ai vu là c'est un truc de fou
vous sortez de Miss France là vous
prenez une voiture et on enchaîne bam
vous êtes la rimd malac de la beauté de
la beauté non mais c'est vrai c'est un
truc de fou c'est la tournée médiatique
ch année la Miss France a le droit à son
marathon de La Presse donc ça va ça vous
plaît oui ça me plaît c'est sypa cont
vous êtes content d'être là oui je suis
contente un peu stressé ou ça va non
pourquoi je devrais être stressé de
toute façon parce que c'est là c'est
presque votre dernière émission là après
vous allez repartir c'est ça après vous
allez enchaîner oui après je rentre dans
mon petit village de campagne donc
justement si c'est ma dernière émission
c'est le moment de souffler ais
tranquille plus vous avez Cindy Cindy tu
m'as pas ramené de cadeau alors j'ai
oublié parce que on revient de Dijon
vous avais un sacré paquet de moutarde
oublié mais rprs merci sympa les
cadeauxp les cade merde pasarde pour
l'année
prochaine cha fois qu'elle vient c'est
qu' vous amène un
cade un amour tu sais j'en ai gagné des
tournois grâce à toi merci en tout cas
d'être là c'est vrai que moi on n pas
arrêté de parler de vous moi j'ai pas
compris d'histoire sans déconner il y a
eu un truc frère parce qu'elle a les
cheveux courts on dirait frère sans
déconner c'est un truc de ouf on dirait
non mais c'est vrai on dirait qu'elle
avait tro nez non mais c'est un truc de
fou elle a juste les cheveux courts ça a
fait une histoire de fou est-ce que la
question que je vous pose parce que
chaldine avait dit ici elle avait dit F
Gill c'est un peu une
contreprogrammation c'est-à-dire que
c'est celle qu'on remarque tout de suite
tout de suite moi à chaque fois je me
disais tu vois c'est EV tu vois on la
voit tout de suite est-ce que c'était
voulu est-ce que vous êes dit je vais
tenter un truc je vais dire allez ah non
pas du tout quand je me suis inscrite à
Miss fr je me suis pas dit oh j'ai les
cheveux courts ça va faire le buzz on va
parler que de moi non pas du tout moi je
me suis inscrite c'était vraiment juste
pour mon plaisir personnel j'avais
absolument pas pensé à mes cheveux ah
vraiment
ça fait longtemp que vous avez cheveux
course ça coupé y a 3 ans sur un coup de
tête ma mère m'a dit oh j'en ai marre
tes cheveux traînent tu les coupes j'ai
dit ok elle m'a dit non mais je rigole
j'ai dis pas moi non ah oua faire les
cheveux
bientôt peutêtre jour
maisle non donc ça fa ça fait 3 ans donc
c'était pas que pour Miss France c'est
ça parce que moi je me suis dit moment
Jere elle a voulu dire je vais me
démarquer des autres parce que ça aurait
été une bonne une bonne tactique
franchement oui non parce que je me
résume pas une coupe de cheveux donc non
c'était absolument pas c'était
absolument pas stratégique vous faites
quoi dans la vie moi je suis en licence
mathématique j'adore
math calcule mat x 6 26 x
12 vous voulez faire quoi plus tard
statisticienne non j'adore ça moi je
suis un foot statisti et ça sert à
quoi non mais c'est juste étudier avec
j'ai un bac un bac général général
lequel et maintenant il y a plus S
non mais du coup j'ai fait mathématique
et SVT en terminal mention très bien non
mention Très Bien arrête de charer
remettez-lui des
cheveux non non mais quoi tu as eu la
mention Très Bien ou je te crois pas oh
c'est comment c'est 16 de moyenne ça
ouais imprn 19 en philo je suis un fou
de philo moi c'est c'est qui votre
philosophe préféré ouis parce que vous
êtes F de
Phil mais mais c'est qui votre
philosophe préféré tiens je pasêre
philosophe préféré vous les aimz vous
les aimez tous non c'est pas que je les
aime tous c'est que Y a c'est un peu
comme pour à chaque fois on pose quelle
Miss France tu aimes quelle personnalité
tu aimes c'est en fait j'ai pas de
préférence et à chaque fois je préfère
prendre un peu partout plutôt que
d'avoir une seule icône moi j'adore
Nietsche par exemple j'adoris ce gars
ouais Jo Bayern Jo Bayern
m ça vous a énervé les les critiques sur
les réseaux sur vos cheveux ou pas tout
le monde vous a posé la question je vous
la repose parce que c'est insupportable
ah oua je les ai juste pas regardé j'ai
faill insulter des gens moi sur les
réseaux encore ah non moi j'ai fait
l'autruche j'ai la tête dans le sable
j'ai rien regardé je j'y faisais pas
attention faisais plus attention aux
commentaires positifs aux messages de
soutien plutôt qu'au commentaires
négatifire vous sentiez que vous aviez
une grosse chance d'être miss France ou
pas du tout mais de toute façon moi je
ne visais que la couronne je me suis
pass à un moment dit je ve participe
juste pour participer ah ouais en fait
par exemple quand on a appelé les 15
j'attendais mais j'attendais qu'on
m'appelle vous saviez que vous allezer
ouais aucun doute je savais au fond de
moi ah ouais fort et quand vous étiez
que toutes les deux parce qu'on a on a
reçu hier Audrey qui est très
sympathique aussi elle est adorable is
elle nous a dit que des trucs sympas sur
vous elle est très Gentile ouais je sais
et ouais je sais et quand vous étiez que
toutes les deux parce que moi je pense
toujours à ce momentl on se dit là ça y
est là c'est le moment il y a une chance
sur deux qu'est-ce qu'on se dit est-ce
qu'on se dit ça y est je vais je vais ça
va être bon oui B en fait comme je dis
vous avez douté là ce momentl vous
saviez que non non du tout je doutais
pas je me disais ok là vous êtes de ma
famille ou
quoi s s c'est ma sœur la elle ne doute
jamais non non mais quoi jamais vous
êtes dit c'est moi non je me suis dit ok
maintenant j'y suis vraiment c'est une
étape de franchi on est plus que deux
donc ça peut vraiment se passer et je
pense que ça va se passer comme ouais
ouais quand vous avez entendu que
c'était vous vous av dit ouais mon
normal je me suis dit ok c'est bon je
l'ai fait là je l'ai vraiment fait ah
ouais et là et là on se dit quoi après
est-ce qu'on se dit on se dit il va se
passer quoi je me suis dit mon Dieu
maintenant qu'est-ce qui va m'arriver ah
ouais et alors et qu'est-ce qui se passe
juste après bah c'est la tournée presse
3h de sommeil dans une voiture et on
enchaîne interview photo
interview c'est ça ouais c'est un vrai
marathon elle a pas le temps de
comprendre ce qui lui arrive il faut
automatiquement remonter sur une
couronne elle part qu ou c'est comme
après la galette des rois je te jure d
j'ai la je mets la couronne je me barre
il y a des interviews et tout c'est un
truc de fou puis pour être surtout en
direct au journal de 1h c'est ça doncou
c'est ouf hein et tu as été tu as été
bien tu as kiffé anim la soirée ou pas
oui on m'a dit de prendre du plaisir
c'est ce que j'ai fait on prend toujours
du plaisir à côté de je-pierre Foucou ce
que m'a dit sa femme euh je l'embrasse
Eveline jeembrasse audelà de la la
beauté de la jeune fille j'ai beaucoup
aimé ce qu'elle a dit quand elle a dit
qu'il fallait être soi-même qu'il
fallait pas être ce qu'il faut mais être
soi-même je TR TR pas porter un masque
de toute façon le public n'attend que ça
n'attend d'avoir une vraie personne si
je porte un masque une semaine là dans 6
mois on va me retrouver comme du
n'importe quoi dans la presse oh mon
Dieu qu'est-ce qu' a dit alors que si je
suis moi-même dès maintenant les gens
savent à quoi s'attendre donc alors euh
j'ai retrouvé des photos de vous avec
les cheveux longs je vous les montrer
dans un instant euh pour le moment on va
revoir le défiler en bikini c'est un
moment très attendu tous les ans lors du
concours m France c'est un moment
difficile ça ou pas non ça a été quoi le
moment le plus difficile
euh non il y en a pas en fait parce que
j'adore la scène donc j'ai juste pris
plaisir je diraai plus le moment que
j'ai préféré du coup le rock and roll
c'est que ça soit musique Coré c'était
un pe pris toutes les Corées comme audre
nous l'a ditou c'est une grosse tanasse
franchement une fois qu'on a compris la
mécanique ça va ah ouais ouis ok on va
faire comme ça parce que je comptais me
présenter l'année
[Applaudissements]
prochaine France 2024 est avec nous euh
alors peu de gens l'ont vu mais vous on
vous a vu glisser légèrement à cause de
votre robe lors du défilé moi je l'ai vu
alors on m'a vu une fois pourtant j'ai
glissé quatre fois ah ouais ouaist bah
après c'est les risques du métier on a
de longues robes on a des talons le pied
de sur la robe et ouais on va on va
revoir ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
regarde
Gliss Ann ça passe ça passe ça passe
alors le moment le plus important pour
moi c'est quand même le discours c'est
là que c'est là qu'en
faitours c'est là ça bascule passe ou
bien moi par la
pauvre je pense qu'elle éé elle était
dans les favorit et la pauvre est pass à
côé pour ça que tuas pas été Miss France
nul discours je sa je su n c'est le
moment le plus
attendu moi c'est ce que j'attendais moi
j'attendais j'isoué
philos est- est-ce que vous êtes plutôt
ragou ou bagou non mais j'ai pas compris
les B aprs on va revenir làdessus mais
juste le discours de regardez bonsoir la
France bonsoir Le nordpcalis un petit
coucou à la Réunion et aux membres du
jury je m'appelle Gill j'ai 20 ans et ce
soir être parmi vous et ma plus belle
revanche j'aimerais grâce à ma
participation montrer que le concours
évolue et la société aussi que la
représentation de la femme est diverse
selon moi la beauté ne se résume pas à
une coupe de cheveux ou à des formes
qu'on a ou pas pour moi c'est bien plus
que ça personne ne doit vous dicter qui
vous êtes ou doit vous faire rentrer
dans une case la diversité le changement
peut parfois faire peur mais il faédère
aussi ah et d'ailleurs au cas où vous
auriez un petit doute la couronne
tiendrait très bien même sur mes cheveux
courts
merci merci merci ah oui tu l'as écrit
toute seule ça pardon tu as écrit toute
seule ça tu as préparé toute seule euh
on l'a préparé ensemble avec mon comité
en fait ils savent ce que j'ai envie de
dire je sais ce que j'ai envie de dire
après on on voit ensemble les nuances de
voix tout ça parce qu' ah tu as préparé
même les nuances de voix oui vraiment on
s'entraî parce que déjà on a un temps
donc on essaie de chronoméer
pour puis même les téléspectateurs vous
imaginez si on avait 15 minutes je sais
moi je me Seris paré et même moi moi non
moi avant euh franchement non mais c'est
vrai non mais et bon non non ça serait
trop long mais donc non tout est préparé
tout est préparé mais c'est bien vous
l'avez fait naturement après on a
surtout des mots clés plutôt que une un
vraiment un discours écrit phrase par
phrase c'est plus des mots clés pour
faire plus naturel vous aviez flippé tu
as flippé là ou pas euh non cétait enfin
oui et non parce que d'un côté on est
complètement préparé mais un autre on se
dit que là c'est le moment où tout le
monde nous regarde tout le monde nous
c'est là ça joue une boulette et énervé
d'ailleurs je vous dis la vérité en tant
que profession un peu énervé sur un truc
ça avait été super je vous mettiez votre
micro un peu de côté ouis ça m'a énervé
j'ai faill dire ouais
oh heureusement je suis pas Jean-Pierre
fouco moi ça serait parti en pugila
là-bas Jean-Pierre il a la classe tu
vois fait s'il vous plaît non mais c'est
vrai non mais voilà mais sinon c'était
super merci cé elles ont toutes eu des
discours très préparés mais aussi
spontanés donc c'est ouais c'est vrai
après il y a eu Miss il y a une Miss
Miss je sais plus laquelle qui avait pas
préparé Île de France France un truc de
fou oua mais au final c'est ce que les
gens ont aimé c'est de la spontanéité
c'est oui elle a dépassé les une minute
bah oui quand on prépare pas c' marrant
quand elle a dit ça c'était marrant j'ai
bien aimé bravo bravo tuas Cindy elle
les trucs Cindy j'adore j'adend mon
cadeau Cindy on a retrouvé des des
photos de vous puisque BFM a retrouvé
votre coiffeuse à Berg qui est très fier
d'avoir réalisé votre coiffure mais
surtout on a des photos de vous quand
vous aviez les les cheveux longs cétait
tout jeune regardez les les photos B
voilà donc est où est là de con c'est la
Seu qui pas
fouté sont con B est où sans estcné mais
mais mais qui m'a mis une équipe comme
ça non e bah ouais c'est c'est un délire
c'est un délire mais franchement les
chevaux courts je pense que si vous
aviez eu les chevux long vous n'auriez
pas été élu c'est comme c'est comme inda
Evangelista elle faisait pas carrière on
lui a coupé les Ch elle est devenue une
énorme
star Verdez hein il avait pas de cheveux
ça a poussé non j'ai pas envie de dire
parce qu'il y a Miss Fran je dirais pas